elle encourt huit mille masques ont été
fournis aux enfants un coût financier
pour la commune mais nécessaire c'est
très lourd je rappelle que la compétence
santé général c'est l'état c'est pas les
collectivités mais bon on doit faire
face nous on est à proximité des gens on
voit alors leurs inquiétudes surtout les
enfants
il faut être présent il faut résoudre le
problème voilà en tout cas ce effet
prévenu jeudi difficile de s'organiser
pour les parents cette aide est donc la
bienvenue
c'est gentil ça nous aide parce qu'en
dernière minute on en avait pas donc
c'est pas plus mal
ils l'ont fait aux premiers confinement
pour nous donc c'est gentil de le faire
pour les enfants aussi très bien qu'à la
ville distribue des masses parce que
c'est pas évident de se trouver des
masques enfants comme ça du jour au
lendemain à villepreux 1800 masque
lavables ont été commandés par la ville
chaque élève de l'école élémentaire en
aura deux s'étaient pas obligatoire
effectivement mais on savait et ça a été
dit que l'éducation nationale n'avait
pas prévu de doter l'ensemble des
enfants en masque éventuellement plutôt
les familles fragilisées ou qui était le
plus dans le besoin
nous nous avons décidé d'aider
l'ensemble des familles proviennent et
de les accompagner donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on n'a pas tergiversé on a
décidé très tôt dès jeudi matin de
passer commande et les maths sont
arrivés vendredi soir
certains étaient déjà équipées d'autres
pas mais la majorité des parents
présents à la sortie de l'école apprécié
ce coup de pouce nous on en avait acheté
parce qu'il en avait déjà parlé mais
c'est vrai que la mairie a fait un gros
geste vis-à-vis des enfants
c'était donc une rentrée particulière
pour les enfants reste à savoir si le
supporteront le masque toute la journée